[Music]
oh my news hi call me a liar
submitted by I like dog sir jealous man
finds out his girlfriend works at a
naked massage parlor and goes on a
rampage allow me to massage Mandy I'd be
pretty mad too like why didn't you do
that to me what the feet is a naked
massage parlor I didn't even know those
existed because if I did I've been
sitting up I've been going to the wrong
one you've been having fun Asian men
balls on your forehead yes I always get
the men too
I got naked at a massage parlor and
there was a man that massaged me no
usually the person getting massaged gets
naked for not the person giving them
massages so this was a hot-ass girl
it's just massaging you at this parlor
both of y'all are naked customer and
today shave what is this this one is in
- okay that just sounds like a brothel
yes example it's like sex the holes in
this thing or is it one of those like
I'll give you a [ __ ] and then I'm
gonna do to my knowledge all I know is
that it's just the customers naked and
employee it's just is naked as well but
employees massaging customers I would be
thoroughly upset though if I'm just
getting a massage and the massage is bad
and it's just a naked
you don't sane because like it's okay if
they're calling for the rim no but it's
okay if they're naked if there's sex
involved but if I'm just going for a
massage and they're just naked and I
just get to look at them it's like [ __ ]
that no I need the massage I don't think
you would go there if you really wanted
a massage I think you go there for I can
no I'm saying I can is the part that
bothers me that both of us are butt
naked but you guys are hot is that we're
not having sex unless they massage you
and then you jack yourself off because
you might just go to a [ __ ] strip bar
or so you know both from what I've read
the way to describe this massage parlor
doesn't have anything sexual
it's just everyone naked the fact that
if they're naked is already sexual so
you could just Jack yourself off while
they're like massaging your son besides
myself and then I'll relax fall asleep
and then you could
discount sex McAllister lied to her man
she did like what she said she was a bad
girl Robbie no she said that she worked
at a cafe cafe of [ __ ] I worked an
efficient ship space so this is
Christian this is why you look at
Christian to boyfriend you look jealous
he looks like he works for like the
Russian mob or something yeah he looks
like he's her pimp he steals cars on
Sundays check o of the Lord's Day why
don't we have the Mickey Mouse hand I
speak the exact Mickey Mouse her how old
is he 26 Wow we looked like [ __ ] for 26
bro hey he's the victim here he's been
through a hard time
he looked like a prison picture probably
got such kids which he did okay that
make sense then what did he do his
girlfriend told him guys like oh I work
at a cafe right and so he believed her
and then he later found out from a homie
that she worked at a naked massage
because he got massaged by her I don't
know if he got my smell by her he just
saw her and he was like hey she works
there and then so I woke up and there
she massaged me I'd be jacking off to
her face for the past week I feel really
guilty but in the spank bank I'm sorry
do you think you would have a friend
like that that night looks like it yeah
he doesn't like that I think so
I think his friend was honest about it
because I've been masturbating to your
girl's breasts for the past two weeks
and I can't help
and so when he found out about this news
he immediately global crazy so when he
immediately found out about the news he
went over to the massage parlor and like
he immediately like barged into the room
hey can I get a free massage my
girlfriend worked here he's just like
what through the store like I swear his
girlfriend was right went into the room
do you have an appointment no she's my
girlfriend
he likes knock down the door dude he
knocked on the door there's a fat greasy
ass whale getting massaged oh my god he
could be I don't know what there was a
condom that booked booked his girlfriend
for a 45-minute massage Oh 45 minutes
she's naked
yeah she's naked he's naked
and he's pissed and so like he or she
starts getting naked and said my
girlfriend's yeah so he he beats up this
customer and like freaking scared while
Shores ball well and then the customer
goes into the closet right and the
girlfriend she runs but then she didn't
run fast enough because like he merely
goes over and beats her holy rats her
like with her hair - wrong I said you
were nice you piece of [ __ ] I told you
here's a next type - that doesn't mean
anything
we have a lot of friends with neck
tattoos and they're all pieces of [ __ ]
or not you understand me if you have a
neck and you're a piece of [ __ ]
you obviously ranked before and then
after he assaulted his girlfriend and
the customer he won over into the front
Rissa of the receptionist phone off the
wall so they can't call the police yeah
and then he grabbed a knife from the
kitchen area and he began like just like
sorry everybody
I mean people have cell phones writers
with just knack more he literally
snapped he what he just saw red you just
think about the mobile phone part though
but I never was butt-naked their phones
probably on their pants or no then maybe
he did think it through good job oh
that's what I'm gonna do tomorrow I'm
gonna go get a massage uh without
massages like a regular Chinese person
massage where they beat you up so then
he was training people and like he was
just like making sure that people just
all stays in the same area and
unfortunately there was like these two
girls I was just coming in for work I
believe one of them was able to escape
because I didn't hear any I didn't be
anything else about her in the report
but one of them was actually forced to
stay oh [ __ ] you go suck my dick it
wasn't until like maybe after a while
when the police came over to try to like
actually stop it but the security guard
like tried to like pry the knife out of
the of the students hands but shouldn't
the security guy in like the arm and so
the cpt guy's like a like that really
hurt and so he couldn't come near him up
until the part that's all he said Mormon
women but you know what though oh that's
really good but this is my favorite part
though because the owner the boss of the
massage parlor she was able to get the
knife all the troubles ahead by pulling
this dude's thumb back my cute
shut up I bet you like oh I mean without
the [ __ ] door you didn't do anything
else that's how visually do you know
anything else at all it wasn't until the
boss of that massage parlor stepped in
and she just took new Christian thumb
and pulled it back and definitely drop
the knife
ah thanks she's dope yeah she's pretty
dope the Sharapova I don't know you know
I think hopefully not accept that guy's
shirt all the way we got butt-naked he
probably would've calm down super fast
you mad all you BAM [ __ ] kids ass what
am i doing bro he's so stupid he could
have got a threesome you know with what
the custom degrees because the money yep
that's my girlfriend we're both [ __ ]
yeah and so as soon as he dropped a
knife then everybody just piled on top
of him
well does the chicken one naked girl
just all over him I always a good
Sabbath here guys is my right now if
some crazy [ __ ] right now dude is
fantastic watch it's like all the making
customer guys that jumped on you have
all these like old rich guys all greasy
that's sliding off the Machine titties
landing on top of them and I see you
can't hold up the whole sphere you
[ __ ] bugger mmm
would you want that massage oh yeah all
don't forget the water snakes
why don't we leave yeah that [ __ ]
sucks what happened to the girlfriend is
she okay
all I know is that right now he faces 32
months in jail well as automatic
deportation to Romania for his crimes
Virginia criminology does look Eva's
with East European assist or criminal
damage common assault and possessing a
blade article as of now from what I know
like he's no longer with that girlfriend
he is actually married and has a baby
what the [ __ ] uh sort of happened a long
time ago humans dog yeah just this
happened a while back but it's news now
because he's actually like in court like
discussing his charges and so what the
judge is going to do is he's going to
send
investor Romania to serve his time and
it's kind of sad too because his whole
family is poor so like when he's in jail
like he can't even make an income for oh
well that's where it goes to show okay
your actions do have consequences my
friend yeah daddy had a baby you should
have [ __ ] just beat her up at home
hey complain your [ __ ] joke come on
lighten up yeah my wife like I wonder if
she knew about his past
probably part turn her on Oh what if
she's like a burly ass woman now she's
like that what you did perfect [ __ ]
hit me Missy what if we met at that
place yeah I was gonna say that oh she's
one of the other workers she was the one
who beeped out of the door turned her on
hard Center eyes he admits to all the
things he's done and he says I wish I
could repair the damages I done to the
parlor but there's nothing of course he
did and trying to get in trouble but you
know what though people after time
people do change so I'm gonna give you
the benefit of doubt because we've all
changed we've all been pretty not that
great people and after we learned you
became better
so I forgive you next at you I think
he's bad I just think he doesn't think
of opportunity could have flopped all
the girls there follow us on Instagram
so you could spy on us like a sneaky
perverted neighbor because you know I
always pump sexy photos for the last
video click over here
[Music]